continuelle de la musique et oui la
ville de guyancourt a donc est à
l'honneur cette semaine avec deux
événements autour de la thématique de la
musique funk le premier donc en fête
organisée à la salle d'exposition donc
tous les deux ans la salle d'exposition
organise une thématique autour de
l'histoire de la musique différents
styles musicaux
nous avons eu le rock le hip hop et
cette année le funk images de guillaume
cambis musicaux c'est de dire comme aux
origines du funk la sueur positive neri
concert à la nouvelle orléans
la salle d'exposition de guyancourt
propose jusqu'au 17 mars une
rétrospective de l'histoire de la
musique funk de sa naissance jusqu'à ces
mutations
l'exposition qui couvre une quinzaine
d'années revient sur les figures
emblématiques et le grands courants
musicaux à travers un parcours
chronologique c'est incontournable
lorsqu'on qu'une expulsion qui parle d
origine on va on va s'intéresser à
l'histoire et le contexte historique
dans lequel n'est un mouvement musical
donc là effectivement le sphinx et la
voix de james brown s'exprime à travers
femmes entre qui exprime le lan de tout
peuple noir américain à l'époque qui
était en pleine révolte contre la
ségrégation et tout ce qu'elle peut
connaître de cette époque là donc
actuellement le contexte historique
jouer est un facteur qui est
incontournable vieux des documents tels
qu'une place chronologique
les visiteurs peuvent évoluer parmi cinq
espaces thématiques où figurent entre
autres affiches pochettes de disques
d'or musical les biographies exposition
qui se veut pédagogique et ludique
propose même un plus jeune
un livret jeu à télécharger pour rien
oublié et puis en marge de cette
exposition il y aura aussi un concert à
la batterie grand concert funk ce samedi
nous avons rencontré le groupe marvelous
au cours de leur résidence dans les
lieux marvelous bande en résidence à la
batterie pour un grand concert funk le
groupe à vocation instrumentale au
départ recherchent dès l'écriture de
leur premier album en 2010
un chanteur au groove d'étonnant la
rencontre avec l'américain wolfgang
belle brune résonnera alors comme une
évidence
bangui l'arrivée il ya quoi deux en deux
ans deux ans on a fait une audition pour
un nouveau chanteur et voilà il va
arriver nous halluciné que sa voix
incroyable à la james
on a dit oui tout de suite quoi j'étais
assez surpris vers mes jeux m'a fait
plaisir de le rue en plein
la formation complet compte depuis neuf
musiciens les marques veulent ou se
définissent comme un groupe aux
influences résolument funk et soul issus
de la musique noire américaine des
années 60
l'expérience musicale de chaque membre
en fait également un groupe au style
empreint de rythmes jazz rock et hip hop
une résidence qui leur permet de
travailler leurs prestations scéniques
dans les vraies conditions d'un live
sont tellement musiciens professionnels
ça s'entend on voit très bien que sur
toute la partie musicale c'est dans la
boîte ça joue vraiment très très bien
on se dit que musicalement tout est en
place après il faut maintenant trouver
une façon de le présenter au public qui
soit optimisé et donc on va on va mixer
le placement les lumières mais aussi
parfois le choix de l'ordre des morceaux
de façon à ce qu'il y ait vraiment une
dynamique qui soit créée autour du
concert et que vraiment on optimise ce
que l'on va présenter au public
m
résidence ne durera que deux ou trois
jours les répétitions auxquelles nous
avons assisté laisse d'ailleurs
entrevoir un show déjà parfaitement
maîtrisé les marvelous seront en
première partie du concert funk
samedi 9 février batterie de guyancourt